il ya 15 ans anne-marie péladeau la
fille du fondateur de quebecor contracté
l'hépatite c
depuis chaque semaine elle fait la
navette entre montréal et saint jérôme
pour voir son médecin le docteur jean
robert bonjour de travers c'est pas
cette semaine j'ai comme une des drôles
de réactions avec avec la consommation
des fois j'ai la lampe torche et la
bouffe le plus mon corps vraiment en
considération puisque quand même
première fois juste mais je sentais
considéré par quelques russie puis et
décider de monsieur le traverse et la
personne m'a sauvé la vie je serais
morte aujourd'hui si elle avait été là
après des années de traitement elle a
finalement obtenu son certificat de
guérison de la clinique santa hmizi sa
plus grande victoire à vie c'est pas
chez seul traitement mais ça prend la
cour agences afin d'éviter les infamies
ça prend une équipe
depuis près de 25 ans la petite clinique
de saint jérôme traite tout le monde
avec ou sans carte d'assurance maladie
un modèle qui permet de joindre une
populations marginalisées et vulnérables
mais la clinique qui compte strictement
sur les dons privés pour assurer son
fonctionnement sur le diable par la
queue
la crimée qu'assume la majorité des
traitements contre l'hépatite c dans les
laurentides de 2014 à 2019
le nombre d'infections d'ailleurs chuté
de moitié dans la région une des
meilleure moyenne au québec alors que
guérir de l'hépatite c est plus fréquent
les entreprises pharmaceutiques
financement les programmes de recherche
la principale source de financement de
la clinique sont amitié auparavant
l'établissement s'appuyer sur un fonds
de roulement de 300 mille dollars par
année mais en 2020 il n'aura accès qu'au
tiers de cette somme directeur général
de la clinique
hugo bissonnet se tourner vers le
gouvernement du québec pour assurer la
survie de l'établissement
est-ce qui vous de fermer c'est son
perso juste continuer dans une certaine
fluidité c'est clair que la clinique et
un risque me suis dit un jour dit les
compagnies pharmaceutiques vont arrêter
de financer bientôt la fin de plusieurs
années je leur dis on va se retourner
voir vous faites comment c'est investir
ça craque développe partout le fait que
je vois pas comment nous nos 5000 nos
5000 visites médicales annuelles con con
qu on offre qu'on est capable de
renvoyer sont en réseau le ministère de
la santé des services sociaux lui répond
qu'il reçoit déjà des financements
publics par le biais du centre sida
amitié un organisme communautaire
chapeau de la clinique
mais ces fonds ne peuvent pas être
utilisés pour offrir des services
médicaux selon le directeur
le ministère avance qu'il peut présenter
une demande pour devenir une super
clinique où un groupe de médecine de
famille
deux approches qui ne cadre pas avec la
clinique santa amitié selon son
fondateur mais sa vache n'importe quoi
nourrir à quelque chose qui marche
pourquoi ne pas l'encourager
le système est pour construit et pas
bâti pour rendre service aux gens de la
ji ce commencement il faudra encore en
vie c'est tous ceux qui sont morts
on adore nathan thierry l'art pions sont
les initiera les morts ne parle pas ne
parle plus le système est indifférent à
son et l'indifférence et la forme le
perfide de mes pays
chaque année environ 1000 personnes qui
visitent le service et si ça venait à
fermer
ben c'est ces gens là qui en paierait le
prix